Rico is with us in Cincinnati hi Rico
how are you I'm doing well how are you
today
better than I deserve what's up calling
because I'm trying to get some some
guidance on like like weird to shift I
guess and the baby steps are kind of
what we should do
I am I'm like one board but my wife is
like David ish so it's been challenging
in that regard we paid off everything
except like a very large student loan of
like 92 thousand dollars we didn't have
a mortgage at the time so I kind of
treated that loan like a mortgage and we
went ahead and finished our emergency
savings and you know should haven't got
getting started on four five and six but
we were kind of not in agreement so we
started saving for a down payment and
things like that or at home and we ended
up getting the mortgage so now we have
the mortgage and student loan that both
pretty much ninety thousand dollars of
each and John said yo should we just
treat those together kind of like a
mortgage and just keep doing four or
five and six
or should we you know I guess get rid of
the student loan and then you know so um
how are you familiar with what we teach
when we went through we went through
financially university like in our first
three four months of marriage we were
like oh here's a married how long ago
was in this was um our early 2017 just
last year yeah okay in two years ago
let's see okay will you flunked okay you
flip the glass I mean we're not totally
on an agreement yeah that's what you've
you know you've just gotta decide what I
think I can't tell you what to do I've
already told you what today when you
didn't do it so you know I don't know
how this conversation changes that so go
back through the Financial Peace
University materials if you want to know
what I think and it'll tell you exactly
what to do which you already know what
today and that is your student loan is
not a mortgage it is not baby step six
it's baby step two and you should have
get off before you today in this crap so
now that you're in this mess you've got
to pay off your student loan before you
do anything else and you need to stop
your retirement temporarily
and completely but I don't think you're
gonna do that because I think you and
your wife make up your own rules so you
know it's whatever y'all want to I don't
care I mean it's not gonna affect me but
if you want to know what I think that's
fairly easy you already know what I
think and you didn't want to do that so
you know you just gotta if you want
follow the baby steps baby step two
includes all student loan debt if it's
nine hundred thousand dollars it
includes it and so you just gotta decide
if you're gonna do that or not if you're
gonna keep a student around loan around
what so long you think it's a pet you're
gonna struggle to build wealth and you
keep doing crap out of order and you
keep not following good financial
planning principles you're gonna
struggle building wealth but you know
you're because you're just you're you're
doing whatever you want to do and that's
what you got to do thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so the reason that we put the baby steps
in place eight million people ago was
because folks needed a clear path that
followed basic financial planning
principles and biblical principles of
handling money and that's where this
came from
and it really has worked so well for so
many millions of people and it's you
know one size fits all well I mean you
know the law of gravity is one size fits
all if you jump off a building 100
percent of you will hit the sidewalk the
law of gravity is one size fits all the
truth principles are one size fits all
and so the shortest path to building
wealth is to not have any debt that is
one-size-fits-all and that's because
it's the truth
and if you're listening to my voice
right now you're not the exception so
you get to decide what you want to do
but that is the shortest path to
building wealth and all the data points
we find from the all the millionaire's
that we've studied it's what they've
done so you guys get to decide what you
want to do but if what you're doing is
already working didn't do what you're
doing
you'll need to ask me
[Music]